WITH THE LINE THAT CONTROLLED
THE GAME TWO NIGHTS A SCORES!
JACK HUGHES LET IT RIP AND THE
DEVILS POWER PLAY CASHES IN.
THEY HAVE THE EARLY LEAD.HAT BI
AND THE DEVILS GET IT DOWN LOW.
DISH.
McDAVID AGAIN AND CONNOR McDAVID
SCORES.
A QUICK THERE.
FROM RYAN GRAVES -- IT
C
DEFLECTED OFF MIKE SMITH
REDIRECTED IN FRONT.IND OF BAIT
AND HE PICKED OFF THAT PASS FROM
STUDENIC THEN AHEAD.ve: LONG PA.
McDAVID IS IN!
HE SCOCO
BREAKAWAYS.
WE'RE TIED AT THREE.
THE DEVILS HAVE BEENTHE DELAYED
AREA BECAUSE THE BACK PRESSURE.T
OUT FRONT.
IT LANDS PERFECTLY ON SHORE'S
STICK OFF THE POST.
DEVILS THOUGHT THE PLAY
SHOULD HAVE BEEN TOUCH IT?
THEY THOUGHT
>> Ken: IT ALL STARTS WITH A
FACE
AT IT.
WE SEE HAMILTON GETS THAT SHOT
THROUGH. JACK